at 93 years 167 days old President
George HW Bush is now the longest-living
president in US history yeah
after hearing us Melania Trump said
please God don't tell me they all live
that long
she likes it the thumbs up we're all
right today is Cyber Monday excited
about that Cyber Monday yeah it is Cyber
Monday it's the time of year when you
get a great deal today on something you
didn't want yesterday good enough what's
my return policy on that joke by the way
the White House Ethics lawyer resigned
earlier today yeah well technically he
didn't resign he was hospitalized for
exhaustion
conan's back on track now he's already
there was a bump there but he's okay
this is weird today two different people
showed up at the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau each claiming to be in
charge
they each showed up each claimed to be
in charge yeah and tonight ladies and
gentlemen they settle it in the Octagon
yeah each time to regulate Time magazine
has been bought by the billionaire
right-wing Koch brothers
yeah critics say buying Time magazine
could give the cokes unparalleled
political influence over America in 1986
really could be
was that something anyone here saw an
actual Time magazine my point
not are the dentist what's that I go to
the dentist I'm there I've tried every
dentist office they don't have time
magazine John Lassiter the creator of
Toy Story announced he's taking a leave
of absence from Pixar amid allegations
of sexual harassment he also apologized
for naming his lead character woody
gotcha Lin don't hear that kind of joke
in South Dakota too much do you
Prince Harry has announced his
engagement to an actress from Los
Angeles pretty exciting yeah that's
exciting so congratulations to Prince
Harry and his fiancee Betty White
I think that's very happy off quite well
that was just silly I want to mention
this a couple in Arkansas who this is
not this is not made-up this is real a
couple in Arkansas who love the Olive
Garden have named yes there are people
that like the Olive Garden
a couple in Arkansas who loved the Olive
Garden have named their infant daughter
Olivia garden yeah Olivia went home
today where she joined her Big Brother
hooters
you
you